[Music]
talk of Peace amid acts of War does
Vladimir Putin have a way out of Ukraine
from Facebook into the mainstream the
news outlets transforming the media
landscape in Italy and pyongyang's Top
Gun Kim Jong-un Cruz on state-run TV in
North Korea
[Music]
hello I'm Richard gisbert and you're at
the listening post where we dig into the
coverage and examine how news is
reported a new front opened up in the
war in Ukraine this past week a
diplomatic one negotiators gathered in
Turkey for peace talks but actions on
the battlefields of Ukraine speak louder
than words do in Istanbul and just hours
after Russia said it would halt attacks
in Northern Ukraine bombs were falling
on the city of chernif what Moscow
presented as a Goodwill gesture going
into the negotiations its critics have
dismissed as a ploy to distract Russians
from the setbacks their forces have
suffered to hear the Russian media tell
it there is no war in Ukraine just a
special military operation and it's all
going according to plan which is why the
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
is trying to speak directly to Russians
to deliver some truths that they're not
getting from Vladimir Putin and the news
outlets the Kremlin controls our
starting point this week is Istanbul
the peace talks in Turkey offered the
victims of the war in Ukraine a rare
moment of hope that failed to last
moscow's pledge to pull back some of its
forces in Northern Ukraine turned into a
broken promise that had a poisonous
effect on the negotiations having
started this past Tuesday the talks
adjourned for 48 hours and then resumed
on Friday the officials at the table are
up against it they represent leaders in
Moscow and Kieth who face their own
political realities and imperatives how
to sell any potential agreement to their
own people
Vladimir Putin and the Russian State
propaganda will find a way to claim the
victory here but it is an existential
conflict between two men of different
Generations Vladimir Putin wants to use
time machine and get back
70s or 80s with the Google Soviet Union
and the young president of Ukraine he is
supported by his population to go with
Ukraine into the European Union so I
don't think it is that these two
different systems could
could exist along with each other those
areas of the donbos under the control of
the Russian army will probably stay
under the control of the Russian army
the big question is what should be done
with the north of Ukraine so those
territories that border with Belarus
will the Russian forces leave those
areas of Ukraine if they do then what
happens to these territories that's a
big question for zielinsky and for the
Kremlin
how to rob up its achievements
as a victory
one can detect in the rhetoric coming
out of Moscow and Russia's shifting
military tactics certain clues about
what an eventual peace agreement might
look like there's much less talk of
regime change in Kiev where Russian
troops have stopped and a greater focus
on Don Bass
in eastern Ukraine which Russia annexed
in 2014.
according to the news channels that
parrot the kremlin's position that means
that this special military operation is
unfolding as it should despite Russian
soldiers getting bogged down on the
battlefield and the body bags piling up
as long as they keep saying everything's
going to plan they're kind of able to
spend this to the public whatever way
they want
um the reality on the ground obviously
is at odds with this but we know from
experience that this won't stop this
propaganda narrative from moving forward
they are just saying that everything is
going according to the plan like our
first phase of a so-called special
military operation was to destroy
military infrastructure of Ukraine and
now the next step is to liberate and
depend on vast which is absurd if they
want to celebrate donbas they could have
done it from the beginning from the
first day to the obviously there was a
plan to take over big cities such as
skies and it did not happen because
Russia just
can't do it we all need to scroll back a
few weeks in our news feeds and we'll
see statement after statement from the
Kremlin denying that it was ever going
to invade Ukraine and mocking all the
warnings that came from the West in
terms of its pulling back from Kiev and
what sounds like de-escalating the only
thing I can connect it to is just it's
absolutely poor unexpected performance
and the sheer scale of Russian
casualties
not that Russians are seeing that story
told on their state-approved news
headlines the gradual Suffocation of the
media space there continued this past
week with The Disappearance of Novia
gazetta the moscow-based paper whose
journalism under already challenging
conditions won its editor a Nobel Peace
Prize last year is the latest
publication to shut down suspending its
operations until after the war
the Ukrainian president has been trying
to get around Kremlin approved news
outlets using social media to speak
directly to Russians last week valada
mirzaleski changed tact doing an
interview with three of Russia's few
remaining Independent Media Outlets
it was zelenski's first encounter with
the Russian media since the Invasion the
news outlets involved have all been
declared foreign agents by the
authorities in Moscow forced into Exile
including TV dodged I don't think that
we were tough of it I don't think that
we were softer we're just asked an
obvious questions
some of the questions were specifically
for the russian-speaking audience
because for example is a rumor about
biological Laboratories there I know
that a lot of people Russia they believe
in it because they hear about it on this
state television that's why it was
important to ask him and to get his
answer it was the first time he had
spoken directly to the Russian press
since Russia launched its full-scale
invasion of Ukraine um and there were
some standout moments in that interview
jelenski's comments on how Russian
soldiers are treating their their dad
for example
he clearly understands that there is a
divide between the people and the
authorities in Russia but at the same
time you know he he wasn't
um trying to gloss over the fact that a
lot of people in Russia do support this
quote-unquote special military operation
in Ukraine as they understand it or as
it's being presented to them by Russian
officials and in state media but really
stood out to me in their interview was
his clear intention to talk to Russian
viewers he's already done a few
addresses where he would switch from
Ukrainian
into Russian language to address Russian
citizens specifically but here he did
this for an hour and a half and his main
message was really that Putin is the one
who's doing the greatest harm to to
Russian speakers in Ukraine
[Music]
moscow's broadcast Regulators banned the
publication of the interview although
they could not stop at circulating on
YouTube and the messaging app Telegram
meanwhile news outlets the Kremlin funds
or controls were feasting on a speech
that Joe Biden delivered in Poland when
the American president went off script
wandering away from the words on his
teleprompter and throwing in a little
extra on Vladimir Putin for God's sake
this man cannot remain U.S officials
spent the next two days quote-unquote
clarifying the president's statement
insisting that the U.S is not intent on
regime change in Moscow no one on the
state approved Airwaves in Russia buys
that for years Russian propaganda on
television has been asserting exactly
this that this is America's goal its
goal is to bring down Vladimir Putin and
with the Russian people yeah
as something that they're fighting
against Ukraine but they frame this as a
war against the U.S the ongoing war with
NATO with the West all of whom instead
of sending their own soldiers to fight
against Russia are using ukrainians to
attack Russia judging by the Rotherham
coming from the Kremlin they truly treat
Ukraine as a puppet state in the hands
of the United States and therefore all
the referee and even the military
gestures like bombing Western regions of
Ukraine while Biden is in Poland they're
just symbolic gestures to show that we
know what he wants to do to us we know
your plans for Ukraine therefore we are
ready to engage in this battle of
gestures and
it's not going to be decided at this
talks in turkey or wherever it's going
to take place next
sticking with Ukraine and the Chechen
component the leader of that Russian
Republic ramzan kadiroff has ordered
some of his forces into the battle where
he is playing an active part in the
information War Tarak NAFA joins us now
with more on the man they call Vladimir
Putin's attack dog
on February 25th the day after the
invasion this was the scene in
chechnya's capital grazmi ranzan kadirov
wearing military fatigues in a pair of
Prada boots assembled his forces in a
show of combat readiness
[Music]
um
since those troops were deployed to
Ukraine they've also invaded social
media in some videos that were quite
obviously staged
[Music]
here's the thing though the chechens
don't appear to have had much impact on
the battlefield they seem to be spending
more time on their phones than in actual
combat and observers say that's their
real purpose fighters in Putin's
propaganda War kadirov has always been
preoccupied with his online image he
built a big following on Instagram which
he used to project power in chechnya and
demonstrate his usefulness to the
Kremlin that was before Instagram banned
him in this war telegram has been his
platform of choice we've seen videos of
him alongside his troops as well as
public displays of piety clearly
designed for a Muslim audience
of the Chechen leaders forces are known
have a reputation for ruthlessness and
brutality they're responsible for
abducting torturing and killing kadiros
critics
chechens who speak out have been
punished along with their families some
are even paraded and publicly shamed on
state TV that's the reputation the
chechens have brought with them to
Ukraine but if they're poor fighting
performance and lackluster propaganda
efforts or anything to go by the
mythologizing of kadira's men has been
very much overplayed
thanks to Ark it started out as a
Facebook page one that focused on a mix
of what Italians call chronica General
news along with a lot of gossipy click
bait in the decades since fan page has
grown into an award-winning
investigative news site it is one of the
new digital first news platforms
gradually reshaping the stayed Italian
media landscape they cater to a new
generation a tech savvy one that's
disillusioned with Legacy Media outlets
and their traditional means of
distribution mobile first Outlets that
are better at listening to Young
audiences and at speaking their language
the listening posts Flo Phillips now
from Naples on a Facebook page turned
news source that symbolizes a shift in
the country's media
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
a naples-based reporter for one of
Italy's most popular online newspapers
fan page pretended to be Laura
working undercover with the website's
investigative unit she took viewers on a
journey into the world of anti-vaxxers
conspiracy theorists and covert deniers
[Music]
the result of that six-month project
three films entitled
or the super spreaders an investigative
Trilogy that added to the list of
journalistic exposes that have helped
fan page make its name
covering stories about political
corruption and pedophile groups scandals
involving the Catholic Church
businessmen and criminals fan pages
investigative output has had tangible
effects
if we want to pinpoint one moment when
fan page acquired real Nationwide
significance it was after the bloody
money inquiry into the illegal
trafficking of waste in Italy
there was an undercover investigation
and it had a tremendous impact it
involved different political figures and
led to a number of arrests foreign
at that point
but fan page had existed before that and
it already had a readership in the
millions it's not just about undercover
investigations there's so much more to
it than that
traditionally investigative journalism
is the jewel in a news Outlet's crown
and fan page has been very smart in
making investigative journalism one of
its Specialties their investigations
give it its high profile and their
counterbalance with more light-hearted
content celebrity gossip that draws
large audiences and brings in the
revenue to pay for the longer form
content just think in 2021 fan page
became the fifth most popular online
news Outlet in Italy with 19 of the
market shareit
fan page got its start in 2011 as a
Facebook page and its editor-in-chief
Francesco cancellato still calls
Facebook the site's big brother but it's
come a long way
in a landscape dominated by Italian
broadsheets familiar names like IL Korea
De Sierra La Republica La stampa fan
page has stayed away from print there's
no need its YouTube Community you media
equals that of La Republica and El
correada De La Sierra combined and its
various platforms boast viewing numbers
of more than 10 million
while its undercover investigative
journalism strikes at the heart of
Italy's political power it is fan Page's
exclusive interviews and slickly
produced videos that drive the daily
hits
cancellato says fan page is up there
with the established newspapers but with
one major difference
it's DNA unlike the majority of
newspapers in Italy stands out because
our editor has no conflict of interest
and that means the paper can tell
stories as they are I believe this is
what makes fan page different from other
titles it was true 10 years ago and it's
still true today
so does something as simple as fan
Page's location like Legacy Media
Outlets the website has offices in the
political Capital Rome and the financial
center Milan but its headquarters are in
the south of Italy here in Naples a city
known for its unemployment under
development and a reputation for
organized crime fan page is bridging
Italy's north-south divide offering
journalists born and raised here the
chance to tell stories from the south
and give them a national platform
reporters like Gaia martignetti a native
Neapolitan who says she never thought
she could make a career of Journalism so
close to home foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
page in her late 20s and found that most
of her colleagues were of a similar age
in an industry traditionally made up of
middle-aged Men new digital first
Outlets sites like fan page ill past and
open tend to skew Young
open is a youth-oriented online platform
founded by one of Italy's most
established journalists Enrico mentana
a few weeks ago he posted a job ad in
search of four new hires among the
prerequisites applicants had to be young
idea was to offer young journalists a
start in this industry I wouldn't call
open a journalism School exactly but a
kind of lab where we train new
journalists
when we started our operations in 2018
mintana would say to us first you need
to learn how to bake bread three years
down the line I think he was right open
has learned how to bake bread we've
managed to establish ourselves in the
journalism industry as a reliable source
of verified information with an in-depth
presentation and fast delivery
Enrico mentana is very experienced in
and knowledgeable about the Italian
publishing industry and he spotted a
niche overlooked by traditional Outlets
so open emphasizes fact checking and the
debunking of fake news on social media
similarly Luca sofris IL post
concentrates on so-called explainers
and then of course fan page focuses on
investigations these Outlets have all
been successful because they've honed in
on a specialization specialization
for younger digital only Outlets out to
compete with established media Giants
such specializations can make all the
difference
lacking the legacies and reputations of
Italy's mainstream newspapers these
mobile first Alternatives walk a bit of
a tightrope balancing the need to feed
older audiences news content in forms
they are familiar with while targeting
their younger audience with Niche
content that speaks to them
there's a saying I like a lot which is
New Media old values it's true that
mobile first journalism has its own
language its own style but the
fundamentals remain the same and those
fundamentals are essential for open I'm
conscious that our goals are extremely
ambitious perhaps too ambitious to
Encompass all the diverse challenges we
face but hey that's where all the fun is
and standing still has its dangers as
fan page can tell you its audience might
be on Facebook one year Tick Tock the
next
if there's one lesson Italy's old guard
Outlets can learn from the new ones it's
this adapt or die innovate or risk
irrelevance and possible Extinction
this is what really drives us constantly
experimenting innovating and changing I
believe it is our duty our mission to
bring about Innovation to the media
landscape in Italy I don't feel I'm in
competition with
my real competitor is anyone who is more
Innovative than I am
foreign
[Music]
and finally having skillfully avoided
covering the news coverage of last
week's Academy Awards ceremonies and the
slap heard round the internet we'll end
with a short video which should be
nominated for an Oscar of its own the
category would be worst performance by a
global leader on fawning state-run
television while launching an
intercontinental ballistic missile that
would be North Korea's Kim Jong-un who
officially disapproves of almost
everything American but who clearly has
a soft spot for Tom Cruise in Top Gun
the leather jacket the shades and before
you go after Kim for dressing up like
it's 1986. keep in mind there's a Top
Gun sequel coming out next month and you
know they'll be watching in Pyongyang
we'll see you next time here at the
listening post
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]